[Music]
thank you
David so lovely to see you it's good to
see you Tim and I had
thanks to your inspiration fine matcha
before sitting down to have this
conversation thank you for that well I'm
honored to inspire you on something like
that so
you inspire so many I'm putting together
the the coffee matcha alternating
schedule which seems to be working very
well for me so far so thank you for that
and I'm excited to have you on this show
for many reasons one of which is this is
in a way a debut an audio long form
debut so I'm I'm very
thrilled to be able to explore a lot of
these things that will be scratching my
own itch in terms of asking questions
that follow my curiosity so let's begin
not exactly at the beginning not at
conception but
a beginning of sorts and that is with
Michael Ovitz how did you first connect
with Michael Ovitz and who is Michael in
the mid-1990s Michael Ovitz was the most
powerful person in Hollywood slash
entertainment by far he had created
creative artist agency
which was already that time the biggest
talent agency in Hollywood and he had
created this leverage by controlling so
many stars and by being this very
mysterious figure that he just became
almost like The Wizard of Oz like some
mythical creature and
I remember I was debating a career
switch I was working in Consulting for
entertainment companies with Boston
Consulting Group at the time
and
decided that my love of Hollywood and
movies I had to move out to Hollywood
and really try it and not have regrets
and he was on the cover of business week
and I just cold called him I called I
sent him a letter old-fashioned paper
resume you know went to Kinkos to print
it out and
I was granted a five minute interview
and flown out to LA and so that was the
first meeting I remember he put me up at
the Beverly Hills Hilton and he made me
stay two days waiting for the meeting
like he just kept getting delayed you
know
so to dig into a few aspects of that um
we're talking about The Wizard of Oz at
the time right Wizard of Oz in
entertainment a power broker
of high order he must have been having
everyone and their grandma and cousin
trying to get a hold of him what did you
say in your cover letter or what was it
in your resume what combination of
factors do you think led to you being
Grant in an audience with the Wizard of
Oz
I think I pieced it together after a
while you know I I was fortunate to have
a stellar resume but so do a lot of
people that I'm sure we're approaching
Michael at the time
and it was
in retrospect I think I can say this now
Michael had been hired by Matt susta the
Japanese company to secretly analyze and
potentially sell their holding of
Universal Studios which they had bought
years earlier
so I was in the right place at the right
time he as a great agent would do he
sold that assignment but he didn't
necessarily have people that could do
the work for him and all of a sudden he
got this Harvard MBA resume of some guy
saying he'd be willing to work and take
whatever and you know in many ways I
think it was just a really fortunate
timing that it came across his desk then
and you had the relevant experience in
mergers and Acquisitions or that type of
deal analysis or no no
I sort of joke I mean I I was very into
creative things and I turned that part
of my brain off after graduating from
duke because I needed to make some money
and I figured my rational brain was more
predictable and so I went to to HBS and
I had the Harvard Business School
moniker
and I had a couple years at Boston
Consulting Group but I think once I
learned Michael and once I started
working with him that was the first job
which was to secretly help him on that
assignment which was
amazing as your first job in Hollywood
to have this huge secret you couldn't
share with anybody in town
I would had his office way in the back
so none of the other agents would know
what I was doing and I was getting these
secret emails between Universal and the
Japanese at the time that Lou Wasserman
another mythical figure was not even
privy to
so it was it was a blast but I think he
he enjoyed having his token Harvard MBA
by his side that he could offer up to
his clients and he did you know I was I
was there for whatever
that moniker might deem to be useful for
for whether it's Tom Cruise or Warren
Beatty or or a company like matsusta wow
now if we take a step back and since you
came to know Michael very well yeah
you look at what made Michael effective
as a power broker what are some of the
ingredients
that made him so effective and
your description as we led into this
made me think of perhaps other
comparables I'm sure very different
people very different businesses but say
like Larry gagosian in the art world or
others who in these fairly opaque
somewhat opaque Industries just develop
relationships that give them
an incredible degree of Leverage but
what are some of the sort of requisite
components ingredients that made him so
good at what he did because certainly he
wasn't the only person trying to be
powerful or influential in Hollywood no
it's interesting Tim because I ended up
being you know I was employee number 400
out of 400 I quickly
because of this secret project and the
fact that it's it became pretty obvious
he was also considering leaving CAA to
run
Universal to whoever bought it
which was cataclysmic at the time so I
had this secret and we flew to Japan and
all that kind of stuff together so I
became to his right hand side and stayed
there pretty much through
1999 2000 so four or five years and
I saw what he's notorious for right
which is a tenacity and a focus and a
work ethic that would not let anything
but his success happen
which was combined with a level of
Street smarts on how this town works and
a
a ability to amass leverage and perceive
Leverage
that caused his wishes to
get executed one way or the other and
then also combined with amazing use of
PR to create this mythical image of
himself and
and personally I was able to watch that
because Michael is a controversial
figure it's you know and that's very
clear
from the history but I was able to look
and see where we were similar and where
I might want to take a different path in
my own career
but if it wasn't for Michael higher and
me and giving me that break I don't
think I'm in a position to do Marvel
Studios ever right so he helped
you know I was naive as hell when I
moved to LA I was smart from a book
sense academic
I had no idea about personal Street
smarts let alone Hollywood Street smarts
I was somewhat creative I felt
but I didn't know how this town really
works and not only did I get to see
Michael Tim I had access to all the
information at CAA all the deals so I
just soaked it up yeah
so I'm going to pick a little bit more
at the origin story not in a critical
way but in a curious way and if you have
to speculate feel free to throw in the
caveat that you're speculating
cover business week
putting himself in these PR positions
that would create a dynamic that might
help him do whatever it is that Michael
wanted to do which I believe he also
imparted to
Mark Andreessen and Ben Horowitz when
they were founding Andreessen Horowitz
a16z and they did a masterful job in
turn of utilizing targeted PR the reason
I bring that up is he's on the cover of
business week I have to imagine you are
not the only business school graduate to
reach out to him right so even if you
have to reach what was it that you're
probably not the only consultant either
who reached out to him so why do you
think you got the
the extensive five-minute interview
right well there's two questions there's
one why the interview in the second
which I think you're related to too
which is why I get hired right yeah
totally the interview one it's a good
question nobody's ever asked me that
before and it wasn't like I went through
three people to get to Michael the
interview I think I spoke to a couple
other people that same day but Michael
was on my schedule right so I had my
time with him
in that five it was no more than 10
minute period
I do remember connecting like I don't
know how but I think he saw
my tenacity
that I was willing and committed to
do what needed to get done
and you saw that through stories of
projects that you assignments that you'd
worked on in the past or it's just a
feeling can't recall what he talked to
me about but you know I'd gone to Duke I
was number two in my class I was on the
Board of Trustees when I graduated as a
student a full board member that's wild
accepted right into HBS yeah it is great
I produced The Broadway Duke series you
know in not that that matters but it was
relevant to entertainment but you're
right I mean a lot of people have great
resumes and I think it was the energy
together but something I've never told
anybody is he didn't hire me right away
right so that interview happened
I I didn't hear anything back for a
while and I started interviewing with
other people I remember I had a job
offer from David Stern at the NBA right
which was wow I mean you were just
talking about the Celtics but this was
like I had an interview with the
commissioner of the NBA and he hired me
to be vice president of entertainment
and I remember he offered me 50 000 a
year and I was like Mr Stern how can I
like live in Manhattan at 50 000 a year
he's like don't live in Manhattan that
was his answer he's like no and I
actually interviewed with Marvel and got
job offer for Marvel at the same time as
head of Business Development
when it was owned by Ron Perlman I
remember their Manhattan offices and
then I got an offer from McKinsey which
was like triple the money which I needed
to be a median entertainment specialist
for them worldwide like a new position
and so I literally accepted that offer
from McKinsey moved to New York City
and started on a Monday
I wrote a letter an email I don't forget
what it was at the time
to Michael and a guy named Sandy clyman
saying guys just so you know I accept
another job at McKinsey right and on
Wednesday I got a phone call from Sandy
clyman who was working for Michael
saying is it too late
for you to join us and I gave noticed on
Thursday so I was at McKinsey for one
week so I don't know and Sandy gave me
a note from Michael for on top of the
letter I sent saying is it too late to
get David so I think it was timing you
know it really was the timing that piece
things together
but I can't explain it a little scarcity
doesn't hurt either yeah having a bunch
of excellent offers doesn't hurt yeah
with him though it's you're right your
sense that he was at the center of
attention and had his selection of
things
I do think in my career when I look back
on it
I was very fortunate with some timing
issues both with Michael
and eventually would Marvel
I had to create both jobs
and I'm proud of that but I also
approached them both at the right time
I think anyone who has ever been on this
podcast who
has achieved outsized success if they're
being really honest has to admit there
is a huge factor of timing yeah which
doesn't demean or minimize the hard work
required to translate that into
amazing outcomes but nonetheless it's an
ingredient so let me ask you just a few
more questions about that period and for
people listening who are like
we want to talk about the creative stuff
we're going to get to the creative stuff
but yeah understand from my perspective
this is all creative stuff and I'll give
you a sense of what I mean
for those people who don't have context
Mackenzie BCG Boston Consulting Group
these are
for many graduates of good schools
coveted jobs highly competitive jobs
they're also firms within which
if you play your cards right and you
keep your head down you can make a lot
of money and it takes time but that is
one potential option and it would seem
to be more predictable
perhaps more perceived as more secure
stable than some of these options you
were looking at yep what led you and a
lot of people go into Consulting with or
investment banking for that matter and
they say I'm going to do this just for a
few years
get exposure to a broad array of
Industries and then I'm going to forge
out on my own and do something
entrepreneurial that doesn't always
happen as you know yeah what contributed
to you at that time deciding to Branch
ultimately recognizing you did accept
the job McKinsey but then ended up with
Michael but nonetheless to explore
options outside of Consulting
it was very personal
I wish I could say I had realized this
on my own but my sister older sister
passed away at a young age and I saw
impermanence and I saw the fragility of
life for the first time and
it did affect me and I knew I wasn't
completely happy not being creative not
at least trying to be out in the middle
of the action and in the arena and
quit BCG soon after that so when I wrote
Michael that letter I was back home
living with my mom which wasn't now
that's like popular to do back then it
really wasn't
and I ended up taking the McKinsey thing
because I had run out of money that I'd
saved from BCG so I like was forced to
take something I think I tried to learn
poker at the time I was losing some
money at the games that were going on
and so it was a gift for my sister
frankly
um to make me realize
that we should try to live to minimize
regrets if possible
so sorry to hear of that and I imagine
that must have been really challenging
for your whole family and for you
it was really a beautiful gift though
because I think I might not have been
have the backbone to like you say
a lot of people talk about branching out
but you can get really secure at those
places and
yeah
I was headstrong in fact when Michael
offered me the job he said what are you
making at McKinsey I told him
and he said okay we'll match that but
there's no guarantee and I can fire you
tomorrow you know so it was a gamble it
was definitely a Gamble
how am I supposed to live in Manhattan
don't live in Manhattan yeah especially
from the commissioner who is just signed
this like huge deal with the owners you
know
it's like come on you're not you're not
like shy for money at the NBA
this is kind of an amazing answer though
you're like I can't really hard to
refute
let's come back to something that you've
mentioned
in passing but the creative interests
that you turned off in favor of
developing or honing in on your rational
analytical mind what were those
interests it was primarily when I grew
up acting in theater
I was an actor in high school and love
life theater and luckily my career
brought me
to have the chance to produce multiple
shows which I've really enjoyed and I
also just love culture and entertainment
Star Wars was a huge impact so the idea
of crafting
Mega cultural movies you know to me as a
creative producer as a business producer
combined was really exciting
yeah and so it was really show business
in general and I knew my acting skills
were not that great they're pretty bad
so but the idea of being a creative
producer on Broadway or film that's what
seemed the most exciting to me
so I want to quote someone and then get
get a little insight from you so this is
a quote from
I believe I'm getting pronunciation
right Kevin duvane yeah as quoted in the
New York Times
and the quote is
David has this is in
sort of brackets but encyclopedic
knowledge of comic books and treats them
like real art with a savant-like ability
to take out characters that appeal to
him and make them really relevant
when did your relationship with comic
books begin
early I mean it was probably like a lot
of us you know something I loved as a
kid probably when I started turning five
or six and Marvel specifically but
overall comic books and in Iron Man
specifically
but a lot of characters like I'm excited
to see the new Flash movie that's coming
out
yeah and it was something I remember my
mom you know I used to joke with her
recently before she passed that
you know she would tell me to stop
reading my comic books and focus on
schoolwork right and it turned out to be
my career so it was pretty ironic and
Kevin who gave that quote I remember
being touched by that because
when I joined CAA back to Michael Kevin
huvane and Brian Lord and Richard Lovett
are the three people who are
predominantly running CAA today and took
over the firm when Michael left and are
arguably some of the if not the most
powerful
agents in town
we sort of grew up together in in the
mid 90s you know working for Michael
and it was unexpected quote when I saw
that
but it was nice to hear his his Kudos
coming from his position and
yeah and I guess we did do some deals
like Natalie Portman was his client who
was in Thor and many others as well from
CAA
yeah so Comics were always an interest
Marvel specifically Tim was a
fascination with me and so even before I
got that job offer when I was talking to
Michael when I was at business school
like over beers some of my friends and I
were like we need to leverage buyout
Marvel from this vitamin company that
owned it and it was completely tilting
at a windmill and nothing came from it
what a fun windmill to Tilt at though
while you're slamming back beers at HBS
yeah that's great exactly wow
foreshadowing I think that's what they
might call that
so before we get to Marvel what are
other lessons that you learned
either from Michael or just during that
chapter of your Hollywood
experience
I would love to just know what kind of
principles or lessons
you ended up absorbing
best practices anything that comes to
mind Tim I think there's a couple that
I'll point out
when was Michael really taught me
how to work with the creatives of this
town because he put me in front of them
I remember it might have been the first
or second time I was ever with him at a
industry function
and he he always and I'll always give
him credit for this whether he said it
or not but often many times he said
something like hey here's a lesson here
you know
and Tom Cruise was there and he
introduced me to Tom Cruise and then he
said we'll be right back and he took me
to the bar and Michael ordered drinks
for Tom and whoever he was with and
brought the drinks back
for Tom and whoever was around him at
the time like you know whether it's his
assistant or
or girlfriend at the time I don't know
and and he mentioned to me just remember
we're always in the service business
remember who's our customers are and the
fact he did that personally and didn't
ask me to go do it or somebody else was
like whoa this guy is at a different
level
um
and I remember the the second day I was
there
he brought me into a meeting with Bill
Gates at the time who was and they
talked about creating like a competitor
to
AOL and you know I saw how he dealt with
the Tekken which as you hinted became a
big part of his life later on and he
always was on The Cutting Edge of
technology so he opened my eyes to
keeping an eye out to what's going on
with tech and entertainment and how
those two industries
are still trying to figure out how to
work together and Michael was sort of
ahead of the time on that
and then I guess third was
you know all of us have to figure out
our our personal style and approach and
you know I saw how there's choices to
get made
on how you sort of learn about Hollywood
and progress through Hollywood right and
that to me was eye-opening because I
also realized I wasn't very good at that
game of like using leverage or you know
the politics of what needs to get done
in a any entity but this time
specifically Hollywood so it was an
eye-opening lesson for me
I asked a professor of mine at one point
what it was like working in DC because
he ended up being a congressman and
spending a bunch of time in politics and
he said it's like Hollywood but with
less attractive people
I just thought that was hilarious and
probably accurate on some level you have
said before this is from the financial
times that to be really successful in
Hollywood you already alluded to some of
this one needs to be very good at
business fundamentals
managing the creative process and Street
smarts to understand the town could you
give an example
of each of those perhaps
case studies times when you absorbed
lessons related to any of those the
business fundamentals managing the
creative process and Street smarts to
understand the town yeah and the first
one business fundamentals it became
pretty clear to me
that that was an area that
Hollywood was not very focused on and to
this day
you probably could make the same case if
you look at some of these Enterprise
values of the studios but the idea of
shareholder value the idea of the what
creates a Disney to be worth more money
or Universal
how do you value a business that you
know
the idea of
value was foreign to people and to his
credit I remember Brian Lord who is
running CAA now
and is one of the most amazing people in
this town I say that in all respects
but I remember
him pulling me aside back in 1995 and
asking me to tutor him on financial
statements and and shareholder value and
all those types of things and now he's
running this huge agency you know what I
mean but he's also saw the same thing
and was wise enough to realize it was
something that he could use to his
Advantage once he learned it
so that actually becomes really
important because later on
I realized the market here was
inefficient right and that the fact I
was able to do what we'll talk about
later with Marvel should never have been
able to happen if it was efficient right
yeah
and then number two the creative process
God there's so many things there but
everything like that that Tom Cruise
story which is understanding
understanding them and Michael also
talked about always the people around
the star that it was so important to
have a great relationship yeah that's
smart yeah and so he exposed me to what
a star like that is used to in Hollywood
so understanding that you know they have
other people around them that will be
maybe whispering in their ears negative
things and so you have to play defense
and offense
I was so fortunate Michael put me in
front of so many people
I remember him sending me to Warren
Beatty's house
just this icon right and still is to
talk about the stock market and I only
say this because it just shows you how
Forward Thinking Michael was
and and he gave me a chance to interact
with these Mega stars on a personal
basis so I got to
training wheels now dude Warren just
reach out to Michael and say I want to
learn the stock market find somebody who
can help me I think it was the opposite
I think what I learned when I got there
because I remember I sat with him for
like five minutes austruck
and then he basically looked at me and
said hey kid there's no way I'm ever
going to learn this I've had too much
fun in my life I'm not gonna start
focusing on the stock market now he
might have used a different a different
word than than fun with an F but
so it definitely was Michael like
tutoring his clients I think Magic
Johnson has been publicly talks about
how Michael would get him a businessweek
subscription and things like that while
he was a basketball player yeah magic is
run with that he's been so
so good at executing wow yeah that's
wild
and the Third Street smarts wow I mean
huh that that one I just realized how
small this town is Tim you know it
really is
it's a small group of people
and still is and understanding what
people want and how you can make a deal
by figuring out
the magic of delivering what they want
but getting what you want back and and
what people's the streets of Arts they'd
say wow I've never talked about this
publicly is to know that it's what is
their motivation are they going for
their annual bonus are they going for
the best seat in the restaurant are they
care about their stock options they care
about their Prestige they care about
credit you know and so many different
people here
are motivated by other things so
sometimes it's it was good Street Smart
wise to figure that out and it helped me
the rest of my career
so if someone is listening and they they
say you know at some point I would like
to set foot into what we would broadly
call entertainment and they suspect
they're going to end up in Hollywood or
LA or at least interacting with groups
from those places
and they're not going to have
Michael Ovitz there they may not have a
direct Mentor are there any
any books or resources or docs or they
could just be scripted movies too that
you would encourage people to watch to
help them with those buckets
I'm thinking about that off the top of
my head
there are biographies of Michael of
David Geffen of Industry figures like
that and I think those are useful
to understand the history of the Town
not you know and I also
am surprised we used to have paper
trades the Holly reporter and variety
they're now all online right but how
many times they interview Young
people that want to come into Hollywood
and they're not really up to date even
on the current stuff that's happening
yeah right so just there's so much
information available that wasn't
available to me at the time you know
diving into history through articles and
through biographies
and and just keeping up every day with
what the latest news in Hollywood is
even just those two things together if
you don't have a mentor you'll get the
the benefit of a lot of learning like in
most areas of life totally and I'll
reinforce a point that might not be the
sexy piece for a lot of folks about the
business fundamentals
it's if you want to as you have done and
we're gonna segue shortly
capitalize on inefficient markets
are asymmetric upside opportunities
having a grasp of just a handful of
fundamentals is so incredibly valuable
and another example of that would be
Bill Gurley who's a spectacularly
successful venture capitalist and
famous mostly well I shouldn't say
mostly but he's associated with
Benchmark and he came from Wall Street
having developed these different
valuation models or at least used all
sorts of tools for establishing value
and got to Tech in Silicon Valley and
saw what you saw in Hollywood it's like
wow yeah we people really aren't
tracking this stuff and being able to
sort of retrofit
those to this new environment allowed
him and his Partners to to find some
incredible opportunities exactly so
let's talk about
Marvel how does Marvel enter the picture
well what happened and it relates to ca
and Michael is Michael did not take the
job with universal we sold it to Seagram
Edgar broughman and famously Michael was
supposed to run it
and ended up not getting the job and it
was given to Ron Meyer who was Michael's
partner at CAA and it was somewhat
Shakespearean because Michael and Ron
were so close and perhaps there is the
paper say Michael might have over asked
for what he wanted from Edgar brothman
but he hired Ron Meyer who ended up
spending 20 or 25 years or 20 years
running Universal Studios
everyone thought then that Michael was
going to stay at CAA
but then he decided to go to Disney and
be president of the Walt Disney Company
with his friend Michael Eisner who was
CEO that was cataclysmic in Hollywood I
remember walking to a meeting that
Michael called
early in the morning to announce this
and then later that day he called me to
his office and he invited me to join him
at Disney
I had a job offer from Ron Meyer to go
to Universal as well and the third
option was to stay with the new owners
of CAA Kevin and Brian and others I love
Disney like I grew up loving the Disney
parks
we haven't talked about this but when I
graduated from business school the job
offer I turned down when I went to BCG
was for the Walt Disney Company
wait for strategic planning Tom Staggs
who ended up almost becoming CEO was in
the waiting room with me at the time
and so I always had this interest in
in the Walt Disney Company and Michael
was my guy right here's my idol now
asking me to join him in his new chapter
so that turned out to be critical
because I then got to spend a couple
years
at Disney where it was like your dad was
the President right so you had open
access to everything you know like I did
at CAA now I'm in a studio and I'm
seeing from a studio perspective all the
games that are played and all you know
how they view the world and I was put in
strategic planning and corporate
development which was a Powerhouse group
at Disney yeah you should explain what
corporate development does because this
kind of like you couldn't script this
movie better you know in a way corporate
development at Disney was Michael Eisner
had this group of people
that controlled strategy and every major
move
under him and they would work with
division heads and essentially it was
his way to centralize Major decisions at
Disney and sort of control those
decisions and I was put in an office you
know next to Kevin Mayer who ended up
almost becoming CEO Tom Staggs who I
mentioned and so we would go to meetings
with Michael Eisner and Michael Ovitz
and I was Michael ovitz's guy they were
Michael eisner's guys and we'd come back
and we all get our phone calls and it
was just a crazy fun time they just
bought
ABC
and I remember Michael Eisner
saying and Ovitz David what are you
interested in I said well Sports and
ESPN is sort of cool you know I'll help
out ABC and because of that I was the
liaison on corporate development with
Bob Iger who was the president of that
division at the time and Steve Burke who
was his number two guy
who became the head of of universal
Comcast later on so I was so fortunate
to be exposed to so much in a two-year
period Tim
you know good and bad about what happens
at a studio like Disney and that's one
of the things my job was was to
recommend acquisitions and you know the
three thread with Marvel I recommended I
don't even think this is public so this
is breaking news I recommended that
Disney by Marvel back in like 96 97
right at the time it was no more than
100 million dollars and I remember
getting kicked out of the room basically
because
one of the first things that Michael
Eisner and the other people in the room
saw was that there was no theme park
rights available east of the Mississippi
River because that was a deal that Ron
Perlman had given to Universal and
because of that
I sort of was
you know not not gently told that this
was a stupid idea what year was this
roughly 96 97 96 97 yeah I'm also
thinking of the kind of state of the art
at the time CGI what was possible what
was not possible in your mind what was
the
selling or value proposition at that
time for Marvel the recommendation what
were the
bullet points in the recommendation for
that acquisition the same as what I told
the Bob Iger you know 14 years later
when I actually sold in Marvel for on
paper four billion you're like let me
just pull this up from 14 years Bob
wasn't the decision maker in that
earlier meeting right right totally he
probably would not have even been in the
room because he was running ABC at the
time but he remembered that and I
remembered it so separate from the
movies like Disney is very good at
thinking about their customer and
they're very strong with all of us as
babies right and we all love Disney and
then normally guys start not liking
Disney when they're early teenagers
right it's not cool anymore
and traditionally that happens as well
with
females at a later age but at some point
you lose interest in what you loved as a
kid and then it comes back when you're a
young parent right and you have your own
kids and so there was a huge gap
especially with guys between like age 12
and age whenever they have kids that
Marvel was very strong with right and so
it just mapped on that I don't even know
if I was able to even get to that point
in this meeting but it mapped on that
whole tremendously well
and that was the driver at this time and
then obviously all the stuff you could
do with the Marvel characters and
I was starting to dream then about
Marvel films in a bigger way but that
idea came to me actually later a few
years later so it was driven more by the
Gap in the lifetime cycle of a Disney
customer that makes sense so you make
the pitch you are very unceremoniously
ejected from the meeting yeah which I
which happened to me a lot by the way it
happened many times
they're like yeah great idea kid not for
right now not for here I'm not sure they
said great idea yeah right so how does
Marvel then boomerang
and come back to you
Michael got fired by his best friend
from Disney
in like 97-98 and there to make a long
story short he again asked me to join
him
in this next venture of his career
and that lasted a couple years during
which he bought a Broadway company and I
was able to produce a show called Fosse
and exercise my first direct creative
project this Broadway show
which did very well and we won the Tony
award for best musical and so it gave me
some confidence which is relevant for
what happens with Marvel later on
and then I chased some internet money
from 99 to 2001 a very famous investment
banker very well known in Hollywood
named Joe ravich who was Goldman Sachs
at the time set me up with a John Malone
company and I lived in London and
Amsterdam for two years which was
great and also scary because the.com
crash happened in in the early 2000s
and then I came back to LA and I was
ready to get back into traditional
business
and I went to work with r Emanuel and
Patrick white cell
who was a guy a great agent who had an
office next to me at CAA and they had
just started Endeavor what is now
William Morris Endeavor this huge
company and they offered me my first
real Payday to work for them for two
years the reason that's relevant as
besides Ari and Patrick being amazing
guys and shows you how small this town
is and they still run that that company
I knew I never wanted to be an agent
long term and so when that two years
started why is that
it wasn't intriguing to me to in an
agency like in a consulting firm or a
law firm there was a role for someone
like me that was a wild card for a
period of time but the real power and
money came if you represented clients
and you could show that you're bringing
in direct revenues and that wasn't what
I did
and I also had my own entrepreneurial
desires and it was in 2003 when I knew I
had a couple months left to go with
endeavor
that I sat down for a weekend and
figured out what has become Marvel
Studios and started that path in my life
okay I'm gonna inflict something
horrible on my audience but I can't help
myself so this is going to be one of
those like Cliffhangers on page 22 of a
comic book ah so Marvel we're gonna come
back to Marvel but I I have to very
selfishly ask you about your
side path into Broadway and theater and
I say selfish because
this I don't think is known I don't
think I've mentioned this anywhere so
this is a first also that I have over
the last few years become one of the
larger investors in a theater production
and it's the first time I've ever become
involved with that and it is they did a
run in
Pennsylvania their first commercial run
and now they're going to be opening a
much larger production in Chicago in the
next few weeks in fact as of the time of
this recording for people who want to
check it out personalitymusical.com
it's the story of Lloyd Price and if you
don't know that name you should know the
name it's pretty bananas how
how many cultural sort of Milestones
this man touched in any case
it seems like a very tough business even
the deal structures have all sorts of
terms that I had never heard before in
my life it's very different from say
early stage Tech investing on a
multitude of levels and yet yeah
it seems like a beautiful powerful
vehicle
and art form in in so many respects what
would you say were key decisions or
events that inform the success of Fosse
I think personal passion in everything
that I've done when I look back at it
I get very focused on whatever project
I'm working on so
and I think I do better if I really love
it and and Theater and the excitement of
Live Theater which you're now
experiencing which is so cool with that
project however it works out is really
indescribably
hard to replicate
it's a little bit like a live-action
film shoot but more unpredictable
there's an audience there it's it's an
animal of its own so that was number one
number two I enjoy I guess telling
stories that have some sort of meaning
to me and relevance and this was Bob
Fosse who was a very complicated man
arguably one of our best choreographers
in America ever and probably the best
one of the best ever on Broadway
and there's a movie called All That Jazz
which I will recommend to everyone to
watch if they haven't seen it
with Roy Scheider and Jessica Lange
which he directed which is really weird
biographical story about himself because
he predicts his own death oh wow he also
was a great film director he won the
Academy Award for best picture I think
for Cabaret
and when I learned about this guy's life
and saw that he died of whatever
substance abuse and womanizing his
lifestyle and and had a very tragic end
I thought that was a really interesting
story to tell and then third he was
known for his sensuality of his dance
and it was like whoa you know I had
never seen anything like that so the
ingredients made me believe that telling
this guy's life story through dance
through his own dances could be a really
cool Broadway project I never thought
we'd win the Tony for best musical
because we had no dialogue in the show
it was literally all his his dances and
the different phases of his life and the
other part I'd say is and it's sort of
similar I'm not afraid to use creative
and business in a decision a lot of
people in Broadway or or any place
entertainment are so afraid of that
because your your title of suit if you
talk about prophets if you want to be
creative you have to ignore that and be
above all that so the creative Mystique
is so subjective that people have in
most cases there's not real
accountability unless you like actually
draw something or write it yourself but
I knew that a story a dance musical
would be very inexpensive both its
original setup costs the set itself it's
just basically a black stage and two
prosceniums the dancers are what was
that term you used the blank stage and
then I think it's proscenium it's like
the arches in a theater okay I hope I'm
saying that correctly I got the image
though yeah I think it was like three
million dollars to set up our set right
which some musicals are way higher and
then the writing cost of the show were
was really low because it was 32 amazing
dancers but no superstars
and so it's also a show that was easy to
tour like you're doing with your show
and so I understood that the economics
of Broadway and
this was a chance the company that
Michael had bought was technically
basically bankrupt so we didn't have a
lot of money to spend on a show
or Market it so out of all the stuff we
could do
I saw that the company owned the rights
to this project and I picked that one
for us to focus on so I was producing
that at night and running the company
during the day
for about two years
for people who don't know and wink wink
might might even be me
I'm sure there are others out there the
word producer gets used in all sorts of
contacts in movies and TV and
theater what does it look like for you
at the time to have been producing at
night what were you focused on yeah so
you're exactly right there's not
accountability in general in
entertainment and titles can mean
nothing or everything right so I'm glad
you clarified that I don't know what the
name is for what I do but I've been
lucky enough with Fosse with Marvel with
my projects post Marvel to conceive of
the idea basically
or see something like Marvel that exists
that has some Legacy or Fosse rights of
and to Envision I guess the first step
is Vision what the project could be and
something that perhaps other people
hadn't seen
and then when I produce it's literally
probably not liked by many people but
it's micromanaging all the various
relevant major creative decisions or
business decisions which might include
bringing in huge creative Talent which I
did on Fosse I brought in his ex-lovery
and ranking to direct who had all a lot
of the dances in her head and I was
dealing with Gwen Verde and his ex-wife
and his daughter Nicole Fosse I like to
Define it there's no Fosse musical if I
don't
make it
and there's no MCU or Avengers if I
don't go to Marvel
so it's having the vision and then going
there and making it happen with whatever
dials I need to turn
creatively or business or political or
financing to get it done
very quickly we're gonna hone in on this
but MCU just for people who may not have
that acronym just if you could just say
what that is yeah and then looking back
at your experience with Fosse is there
anything that
you wish you had known then that you
know now anything you would have done
slightly differently perhaps
so MCU and then the rear view mirror
question
keep it on theater for a second with
Fosse
I was blessed like we
had our out of town tryouts and then we
went to New York and we won the Tony
like it doesn't get much better than
that for a show right yeah yeah I'm
trying to think what would be done
differently with that we were able to
sell that company because of Fosse
success to Bob silerman at the time
and
I remember the investment banker that
worked for me was a guy named Steve
Bannon which was odd but he at the time
he had just come from Goldman Sachs and
what a polymath yeah he did a great job
as my banker and got the company sold so
and that when his name popped up later
on in my life I was whoa is that the
same person and it was so that was sort
of funny I know crazy stories but um I
later on if we want to Circle back to it
I also produced the Spider-Man Musical
on Broadway which famously lost like 50
or 60 million I was gonna say cost a
little more than three million to put
the set together now Marvel had no
capital in it and we had I think 10 of
gross ticket sales so we ended up making
a significant profit from that
production
and it was fantastic to work with
bottomedge from U2
so there's a whole different animal that
the the Spider-Man musical but I was
involved with that as well yeah well
let's hit it straight down the Fairway
between these two poles and just before
we move on since I promised folks MCU
what does that stand for Marvel
Cinematic Universe okay and then we do
the Wayne's World
we go back in time
and you know you have a few months left
in working with if I'm remembering
correctly Ari and Patrick yes and
somewhere in the next few months
the
some of the ideas related to Marvel
start to percolate what does that look
like it actually happened I remember
specifically it was in like October
November of 2003
when I think my stint with Endeavor was
going to finish at the end of that
calendar year
since that story about the discussion
with Disney to potentially buy Marvel
Marvel went bankrupt in 1999. and it had
gotten through a fight between Ron
Perlman Carl Icahn and I promoter and
Ike Pro Mudder successfully got it like
for 30 or 50 million dollars out of
bankruptcy and it had been a public
company for a couple years post that and
achieved like a 200 million valuation
and I was an investor in the stock and
so I watched as the first X-Men movie
came out
Spider-Man of course right
and the stock had sort of stopped at a
200 million evaluation
and
I
took out some old-fashioned paper and I
thought to myself okay what will my next
PATH be right I could you know
potentially stay at endeavor
and William Morris for the reasons we
talked about it was just Endeavor at the
time I decided not to do that
which I think Ari is really happy about
because he very much wanted to buy
William Morris even back then and I was
telling him all the reasons not to and
so I think he was very happy that he
didn't have to listen to those anymore
and he's done so well with that
acquisition so it worked out really good
for both of us and I had another path
which was I could go to one of the
studios
and try to work my way up to be chairman
of a studio which is the only position I
saw where you could be both creative in
business those jobs were what I really
wanted chairman of a studio because you
you green light movies that's the
ultimate power you decide what gets made
and then you can influence that on every
one of those dials that I mentioned
creative or business and it was the only
place where I saw that that really
merged together
some producers had sort of power
but not as much as a studio chairman and
and so I thought about that path to him
and I realized I didn't like it it
wasn't like a law firm or McKinsey which
is somewhat of a meritocracy not totally
but you at least logically you should
proceed if you deliver results I don't
know what the formula is to become
Studio chairman it's just
you know one person selected every 10
years you know they're all in their 60s
or 70s and I I knew I would it was it
would be a Fool's gamble for me to do
that so then I'm sitting there with this
crazy thought of I'll create my own
Studio then by definition I'm in charge
of that studio right and my business
I thought too it has to be something I'm
really interested in it has to have
something that could really be a
sustainable good business because I
needed still to make money could I ask
you a dumb question just as an
interjection yeah because I feel like
it's my job to do that
I just realized as you're talking I have
heard and used this term Studio myself
many times and I don't actually know
exactly what it means to be a studio
raise money and fund production and then
external production companies and teams
kind of take that money and run with it
how much is internal versus external if
you started your own Studio what would
that entail so what does Studio should
mean is that you bring all the elements
to the table you have the money you have
the properties you have people that
either make the films or hire producers
properties meaning the the intellectual
property exactly you either make the
movies yourself or you internal
producers or you hire other producers to
do it and then you market and distribute
the films which is cost as much as
making the movies for a major picture
and so at the time there was six Studios
Universal Disney Fox and so on Sony
and
they made all the movies so everyone
with every IP holder
then and even now would license their
properties to these Studios and so
Spider-Man was famously licensed the
Sony
would make the decision when there's a
movie how much they're going to spend
creatively what it was going to be
and market and distribute that movie and
keep the vast like not the majority but
like 95 plus of the profits wow so an IP
holder like Marvel would only get a
piece of the money and they'd have like
script notes like certain rights but
nothing very heavy
like you couldn't make Peter Parker you
know do some crazy job that would you
know wasn't relevant to the comics or
something like that
Marvel and then normally ancillary's
like toys would be split between the
studio and the rights holder so the way
Marvel got to a 200 million valuation
was off the toys of Spider-Man or the
toys of Hulk or the toys of X-Men very
little money from the movies
and I was frustrated with that as an
investor I didn't think it was a good
model to grow Enterprise Value
and so I was very focused on Marvel
right away so luckily I didn't have to
look at my second choice I knew I was
personally interested in it and then I
had this hypothesis
or model at the time which was I knew
how bad the first movie business was and
you spend in this case 100 million
dollars on something you hope people
show up
yeah research can help you a little bit
but very little it's pretty random Stars
at the time could maybe open the movie
but it's a horrible not a horrible but a
pretty bad business but the SQL business
was amazing because statistically you
could predict the revenues plus or minus
something and you can manage your profit
margin not whether you made profits and
so the big idea I had which was now is
called the universe was What if after
the first movie every movie after that
was a sequel or a quasi-sql which
required all the characters or a lot of
the characters to show up in multiple
movies and that led me again to Marvel
because I knew about the vast Universe
of characters and that this would be
a perfect way in my mind to make every
movie after the first one a sequel or
quasi sequel
and so that it came up like over 24 48
hours that weekend the whole thing and
were you sitting in an ashram were you
flying on airplanes were you having
endoscopy what was going on it was very
boring sweatpants sitting in my rental
apartment across from the park I'm near
Fairfax
where I still have my studio same
building
okay so you're capturing all this on
yellow notepad or yes in your laptop or
wherever then what
so it's a great idea I can see how this
works that was the good news
the bad news was I didn't know anyone at
Marvel
I knew Marvel had licensed a lot of its
properties like Spider-Man X-Men I
didn't know how many that they had
licensed beyond that
I had never made a movie before in my
life right
so there's a lot of things that were
obstacles and in the next month or two
I
got an introduction to a man named Avia
rod and Ike Pro mutter who were the two
guys running Marvel the public company
at the time how did you get that
introduction this is non-trivial yeah it
shows you how small this town is my
lawyer who negotiated my deal with r
Emanuel and Endeavor was a man named
Josh grode who was also aviarad's lawyer
at the time yeah and I told my lawyer my
interest and he said oh I can introduce
you to Avi now to show you how this town
is really small Josh is now the CEO and
president of legendary entertainment
which is a big mini studio owned a lot
by the Chinese and so he's become his
own Studio chairman and pretty powerful
company
with the King Kong movies and other
things like that yeah
so you mentioned Studio at the time Avi
was in charge of what was called Marvel
Studios but it was really a small shop
of giving script notes to licensed
movies Avi successfully
saw the potential of Marvel films and
started licensing the movies post the
bankruptcy
I can obvious known each other
for many years and Avi started as a toy
Creator and he did the original license
deal with Spider-Man he did the original
license deal with Fox for X-Men
and that's what the route that Marvel
was on at the time was licensing these
movies and continuing to license their
films Ike owned I think 40 or 50 percent
to Marvel at the time even though it was
a public company and he was in charge
of everything how uncommon is that that
seems like a gigantic Equity position it
was yeah because he got it out of
bankruptcy he got out of you know
bankruptcy and he kept it and so Ike was
the person I really needed to pitch I
pitched him at Mar-A-Lago in November of
2003 and I remember that flying to Palm
Beach
and having lunch there and Trump came by
who's
was close with like they're still very
close and
I was introduced to Trump and Trump said
something about
he had a TV show starting soon which
turned out to be the apprentice and he
was excited about that that's all I
remember from that conversation
and I pitched Ike in the same way I
pitched Ovitz and
Ike did not see and agree that they
should do their own films right away but
he was open-minded enough to offer me a
job and give me a lot of stock options
a market and and give me a chance to
fight for it internally
yeah and Ike is you know he is now
I think the largest individual
shareholder of Disney
that's incredible yeah
all right so he's like
you can fight this fight
I don't necessarily agree with all of it
up front but you'll have your day in
court so to speak exactly that was it
and what then proceeds
to happen from there I had one other job
that I was looking at which I'm only
going to raise and I've never told this
publicly because of your question about
theater but I got a phone call in the
fall of 2003 from a very high-pitched
voice who said hi this is Michael
Jackson
and he went on to say that he had seen
Fosse on Broadway and loved the show and
it was a personal call I don't know how
I got my phone number and I thought it
was fake right
and he said I want you to tell my life
story through my music videos
and I was like whoa and that turned into
a one or two month set of discussions
with Michael about doing
a 50 50 deal where I'd have
he put in all his music videos and all
the IP I'd be able to produce it and we
both had vetoes on each other
and he even I got him to agree that he
would perform randomly once every couple
months thriller so you'd go to the
Broadway show and you'd see Michael
Jackson actually perform like be like a
lottery right
and Josh Grodd was my lawyer on that so
I have the deal I was going to say
that'd be tricky to figure out from the
legal perspective yeah he was very smart
I gotta tell you he was very smart
business person
and then I I wasn't really seriously I
was gonna carve that out of my Marvel
deal yeah and I think Marvel was going
to let me do that
and then I saw Michael get arrested and
so I let that fizzle right right at that
period of time but it was like the other
thing that I was looking at and then
third Heff was circling me about
potentially helping him run Playboy at
the time
which was an IP company but Marvel was
the part where my focus was the highest
and
I started right away
basically two weeks after that meeting
with Ike
at the end of 2003. now in title what
was your job my title was president of
what was then called Marvel Studios
which wasn't a studio we didn't bring
any money we didn't have distribution
and marketing we weren't making the
movies
but it was called Marvel Studios from a
title point of view yeah okay so he put
you in
the position where you could at least
without having to Lily Pad hop around
the company
Implement what you'd been discussing
yeah this part we're going to get into
which I'm happy to do
like you said in the beginning I've
never talked through in this way and
I've also not done press of any
significant note in the past 10 years so
a large amount of this is still coming
to light
and so some things people might know and
some things they might not but in 2004
we had a very small office Office Santa
Monica Boulevard I think Ike
he was definitely interested in making
more money from entertainment and so my
my job was really how can we make more
money without taking any significant
risk like
had a career of bankruptcy type of
companies Remington and now Marvel and
those those people are not ones that
take big Capital risk on big grandiose
Visions right and so in the board of
directors was a bunch of ex-bankruptcy
guys basically
and Sid ganis I remember who is the
president of the Academy of Motion
Pictures was the the one Hollywood
person there
and so
I would argue for the studio in in the
board meetings and
and it was basically told to
be quiet maybe not those words my last
name was in Spielberg and not bring it
up again
unless Marvel had no risk
not little risk but no risk
conjure me this Spielberg yeah yeah and
what was important at the time is
I asked the board to at least give me
six months and what that meant is not to
license any more movies they were about
to license Captain America and Thor to
two major Studios I think it was Warner
Brothers and Sony
and and Thor specifically was very close
to being licensed
and I basically had to hold my breath in
the board meeting and say if you do that
I can't do anything you know I need at
least those characters to to put
together something that somebody would
Finance as a slate and
and they gave me that six month time and
so during 2004 I put on my NBA hat I I
spent a lot of time in New York and was
able to raise the financing that we
needed was about a half a billion
dollars
of what turned out to be I mean it
sounds crazy to say but for those that
are interested it was no risk it was
non-recourse Marvel never had to pay it
back
you know cash collateral
two things how do you sell how do you
pitch that and then how do you structure
that the structuring uh that's related
it was this idea of the universe
again not a word that we use at the time
but it was the vision of intermixing all
the characters so first to my board the
argument was if we own our own Studio it
means we get the full Financial upside
that that they understood very well
number two we decide a green light when
the movies get made that they also
understood because they only sold toys
really at the time and the toys were
contingent on a movie which they didn't
control the timing of now when you're
doing a public company and you're giving
guidance every year how can you give
guidance if you don't even know what
movies are gonna get made right and so
controlling green light was important
full creative control
I felt that people like myself and Kevin
feige eventually because we care about
the movies would make better movies for
the fans
I'm not sure my board really heard that
point or really understood it given that
we neither Kevin or I had ever made a
movie ourselves like I said
and then fourth we would keep all the
ancillaries as well the toys and video
games so there's a lot of reasons for
for this to happen
the challenge of not having risk is
normally insurmountable thank God again
for timing like we talked about the bond
bubble of 2004 was happening so it was a
time where there was loans being made
that shouldn't have been made
and a lot of people were enamored with
Hollywood as they get enamored every few
years and so I was able to pitch that
give me four at-bats and if one of them
hits then every movie is a sequel after
that and when they ran their models they
were able to get it past their
investment committee to the point where
there was no equity component wow all
right so are we talking about just so I
understand there are many ways to raise
financing so are we talking about banks
are we talking about if so what types of
banks are we talking about who who are
the people you were pitching to agree to
these terms and provide the financing
pitched a lot of different entities but
turned out to be Merrill Lynch
who took the gamble with us and helped
structure it then they offloaded and it
was structured as I mentioned as pure
debt so very low interest rate and
the only collateral were the film rights
to 10 Marvel characters of which we
could make for the movies and
a lot of people misunderstand that they
think we pledge 10 of our characters as
collateral it wasn't that at all because
in the worst case scenario it only got
collected if we lost money on those
first four movies and then those six
characters we owned all the rights
besides film and if a film was ever made
by the bank whoever collected this
collateral we got the same
license fee that we get if we just
license it that day to a party so
there's no opportunity cost so that's
how you would justify it to your board
of directors also right exactly and not
only that worst case we just we get what
we would have gotten doing our current
model and actually even better because
we were able to get five percent of 100
revenues as a producer fee
so even if the film lost money we were
making 10 to 20 million and the bank let
us keep all of the non-film revenues
like toys and video games in a different
waterfall so even if the four at bats
lost we were making 25 million per movie
and that's 100 million dollars and the
whole company was worth 200. so it was
not a deal that the board could say no
to but they also got enthusiastic about
it by the end of 2004. Okay so were
there any hurdles with the board or was
it just so clearly delivering on the
request of zero risk that there was just
no defensible position they could take
that would object to things eventually
when the financing came together but I
it's important for Marvel fans to
realize that it was tender at the time
if if we were not able to raise riskless
Capital like that
the MCU might never have occurred or if
I got there six months later and those
other movies were licensed it would have
been too late anyways
the idea by the way of
Marvel or any IP holder making their own
100 million dollar plus movie was
revolutionary like nobody
to this day I'm only aware of Marvel and
Angry Birds who's done that
and Angry Birds I was part of after I
left
it was a crazy idea Tim and to Ike's
credit he did give me that audience he
he sent me an email that I have behind
me
recently
thanking me for my tenacity
and basically said
I can actually read it one second
this was after Avengers end game in 2019
David the movie was a terrific
accomplishment and we know that it all
started with you your vision and your
tenacity and pushing to achieve that
Vision the word tenacity is about those
hurdles you just mentioned right it was
tough I mean it wasn't
that was a huge Turtle to get over
having the correct financing that would
work
I've never said this publicly I could
have showed up in the boardroom and
given up half the equity and the same
terms for the other fifty percent of the
money
and that would have been easier to
structure and perhaps my board would not
have cared half is better than nothing
of the movie
and I was very greedy I wanted Marvel to
keep 100 of The Upside because also I
was one of the largest individual owners
at that time with my stock options and
so I was very tenacious with Ike but I
was also very tenacious
with Merrill Lynch that we keep 100 of
The Upside
and no deal is easy
they tried to renegotiate
and make us put up a third of the budget
some other way and I was lucky I was not
lucky I was fortunate I guess to be able
to convince them not to do that at the
end
so it was very precarious for a while
and this was renegotiating years later
after they had signed on the dotted line
or this was mid-process we probably came
to agreement in the fall of o4 and
closed it in the spring of o5
and you know things always get
renegotiated until they're closed best
way to put it yeah now all those guys it
turned out to be one of their best loans
they ever made obviously yeah yeah
totally and I'm friends with a lot of
those Bankers still it was a interesting
time
but that was only one of the things
because even with the money that came in
we still needed a distribution deal with
a studio all that money was contingent
on a major Studio putting up 150 million
bucks to Mark in the movie before we get
there it's a very quick question keeping
in mind I'm slow moving from Long Island
no worries takes me a minute or two so
I'm thinking of the numbers here company
is worth
as a publicly traded company I think you
said 200 million right 200 million
dollar market cap you're raising 500
million
to do that I would love to know what the
most important exhibits were and how the
licensed films like X-Men and Spider-Man
fit into that yeah if at all right
because otherwise it strikes me that it
would be perhaps based on industry comps
but it would be
very considered potentially very
speculative you're right I think a lot
of people
are now looking and learning that Marvel
Studios was a relay race you know Stan
Lee and the original comic creators
created the characters
and then the Baton went to Ike and Avi
and Avi specifically doing these license
deals and Ike's supporting him
and then the Baton in 2003 went to me
and then we can get to later on I passed
the Baton to Kevin feige in 2010 and
he's still writing the studio
but
if I didn't have the
numbers of X-Men and Spider-Man to point
to and run scenarios to my board
internally and to the bank
that what if you know we just do half of
those numbers or two-thirds those
numbers for their stress case scenarios
I mean they never ran a stress case
scenario like at doing a third of those
numbers if they did we would have failed
so they wanted this deal to happen
and you know there's incentives we go
back to Street smarts of Mike Ovitz
right what does Merrell want out of this
what does the bank want well they really
they got a I think a three percent
success fee with this deal yeah and they
held the debt for all of probably a half
hour until they flipped it to somebody
else
so
there was incentives for for everyone to
get this deal done
and you know that was important to
figure out dumb question who's paying
the three percent you guys comes out of
the facility okay I'm gonna need you to
expand on that so I've raised 525
million and three percent of that about
17 million I see got it went to Merrill
Lynch right away yeah and who are they
raising it from I'm just wondering if
they're like taking it out of one pocket
and sticking it in the other what yeah
that means I learned this in real time
doing this
because we really didn't have
a banker helping us on this deal too
much
and so it was a man named John turizen
who is the general counsel of Marvel
who is important to mention because he
was the closest person and still is to
Ike and he
he kept my head in the game and he
helped me get through this process and
you know many times I thought of
quitting I probably thought about firing
me and he probably I know he talked us
both off the ledge many times so if it
wasn't for John there's no Marvel
Studios either
I'm either fired or I quit
probably fired
actually it's a pretty detailed thing
but I I was very greedy I wanted the
interest rate to be lower and we got it
insured by a company called the mpac
most of the debt so it became AAA debt
which is then easy to sell to pensions
and easy to sell to individual investors
right so Meryl turned around and it was
packaged with AAA and they were able to
resell it but just and I'm sorry to
belabor this point but no worries my
podcast is basically my
continuing education for Tim Ferriss
program so coming out of the facility is
Merrell
are they basically reselling it and then
taking their three percent after they
have resold it I guess I'm just trying
to figure out where the success fee how
it comes out of the facility I think
they took risk because at the time the
deal closes they're obligated to put up
the 525. so they got their success fee I
think right at that time and then they
resell most of it to other people pretty
immediately I'm trying to remember back
this was 2003 2004 2005. they had risk
when the deal closed I don't know if it
was for a half hour or for one day or
for two days but they had risk for a
period of time before they resold all
that and that's when they get their
success fee once the money's guaranteed
us is one division of Merrill Lynch
paying another division the 17 million
or whatever it added up to sorry to be
late no if they got stuck with the whole
loan yeah then they're sort of paying
themselves I guess yeah I didn't I
didn't think about it that way yeah yeah
okay wow what a world I'm not sure there
was a risk of that when it happened
because most of it was insured yeah yeah
yeah totally okay this is a world that
is largely largely foreign to me but
let's come back to as you mentioned
the other very very critical kind of leg
on the stool which is distribution deal
yeah how did you go about securing that
how did you go about trying to pick I
guess all distribution more or less the
same thing and it's just a different
Marquee name on the same function and
they kind of all perform the same way
how did you go about navigating that
well it was easy because we didn't have
a choice to pick nobody wanted to be our
partner
so at the end of the day only one person
said yes which was Paramount you know
part of Viacom
but the way we got there I mean no at
the time this is really important in
2003 2004 2005 Marvel wasn't the Marvel
it is today so everyone's listening it's
many people probably don't remember that
Marvel wasn't this huge thing that it's
been the past 15 years
and in Hollywood I mean if it was by the
way I never would have gotten this
opportunity right so Disney or somebody
else could have bought Marvel for 500
million you know much earlier if they
wanted to so the studios nobody wanted
to distribute these movies it wasn't
just Sony it was you know Universal and
others we had obstacles now we wanted
great terms
but nobody really believed in these
properties and and you know Iron Man a
new line which is part of Warner
Brothers they had the rights for many
many years and I think for seven or
eight years and never thought it was
worthy to make into a film and they let
the rights expire and give it back to us
so oops it was a very different world
yeah so why Paramount
when I was at Disney
I got to be friendly with a guy named
Rob Moore who was writing one of the
senior people at the studio at Disney he
was vice chairman of Paramount at this
time
he was on his way to a Laker game and I
like tackled him in the parking lot and
just bugged him enough because he wanted
he didn't want to be late to the
basketball game that he agreed to
literally seriously he agreed to like
you know have a meeting with me
and then Brad gray was his boss to
Javier Rodney and so we sort of tag team
these two men and convinced them that
this was a good bet and to your point we
showed him that they were the last money
they put up the last 150 million they
got the first 150 million back so the
film only had to do like a percentage of
X-Men for them to at least get their
money back right so they were yeah sort
of last in first out in two years of
preferences yeah but even with that
nobody else wanted to do it aside from
getting slide tackled in the in the
Lakers parking lot
what was it do you think and maybe you
already answered this and I just
I'm too dense and it didn't land
what led them to say yes in contrast to
all the others who said no what did they
see or how did you refine the pitch
that didn't exist in the other
conversations
I think they listened
and
Rob trusted me from our times at Disney
he knew me pretty well so the past
relationship helped
and he knew I wasn't careless with my
analysis or my statements and so for at
least for Rob I can't speak for Brad but
for Rob
he understood and when he finally
listened to where the break even was for
them he saw it was a good bet right he
in the upside he had distribution rights
to like I think five or ten movies and
the downside you know he basically broke
even if the film didn't do well and
there's a lot of other games like you
know Studios
make money internally even on PNA could
you just explain PNA
print and advertising
so I remember Jeffrey katzenberg had a
distribution deal with Paramount and he
was running Dreamworks Animation and he
basically coached me on what terms I
should ask for and mentored me on that
so we had a deal that was really good
there was no non-cash charges there was
no overhead charge to us what is a
non-cash charge
I mean I understand the wording but I
don't know what it is they would inflate
the costs that they got reimbursed so
they would say they spent 150 million on
marketing but you know 20 million of
that's overhead and another 10 million
some odd costs so like shipping and
handling for infomercial products you're
like how it should be I had like 17
right extra handling man yeah right okay
it's actually it was important because
it can eat up all your profits on a
movie if you get charged too much we had
like a 10 distribution fee which is
really attractive as well
I think George Lucas has the lowest I'm
aware of it six or seven percent for
Star Wars
how the hell did he get that I mean that
was also at the time it's easy for
people to forget but it's like it's not
like that was the Juggernaut franchise
it is today but I don't want to take us
yes too far afield but wow okay got it
so so they say all right worst case we
recoup mm-hmm
best case we have
rights to these things you claim will be
as predictable or similarly predictable
to sequels sure and Tim the part that I
guess with both the bankers and with
Paramount is
I would strongly make the case
creatively for why I thought Iron Man
would be a success and why the MCU which
wasn't called at the time could be a
success
and then also Avi and Kevin would come
into these meetings with the bankers and
with the
distribution Partners to talk about
their experiences on those movies of
X-Men and Spider-Man so we had the sexy
halo effect of of producers on those
movies even though we weren't actually
the full producers and all those things
especially with the bankers were really
important
and with Rob and Paramount
you know I think it was more the
financial
trade for them but
they saw the success of Spider-Man with
Sony and you know hoped that they could
get that upside which they did so why
Iron Man as you know we've we've talked
about this I love Comics yeah I have
boxes and boxes and boxes of comic books
from my childhood still cardboard backed
and poly bagged
sitting in my parents
probably garage being eaten by mice or
something at this point but
there are a lot of characters to choose
from you have a lot of options why Iron
Man
we didn't have that many options again
right so when we closed the financing we
didn't have Iron Man we listed 10
characters
and those 10 characters were led by
Captain American Thor
this thing called Avengers which
people thought was a British spy TV show
and the Avengers weren't defined in our
deal so it could be as with the comics
different characters in The Avengers
right so it was sort of a weird category
of a property there was Black Panther in
there there was Doctor Strange but
nobody cared about those characters at
all that people thought of black panther
as a terrorist group from the 60s
Doctor Strange was a small comic I think
we had Cloak and Dagger in there
shangshi which finally made it as a
movie
power pack which a lot of people know
these names I mean there weren't that
many big names and I'm not sure we even
put Thor in in the beginning because
there was disagreement internally
whether Thor was even practical given
the cost of Asgard
and so for a while we didn't know what
the first movie was gonna be I was able
to get the rights for Hulk back I
mentioned Ron Meyer went to become
chairman of universal from CAA earlier
and so Ron I knew very well and I texted
him
and asked him for meeting and they had
done the first Hulk movie with Ang Lee
which was critically well received but
not box office wise and they were owned
by GE at the time and I said Ron are you
ever going to make a Hulk movie
and he said no
probably not I said what about if I
finance it and you distribute it I'll
give you 10 and he said yes and so
that's why we got the Hulk back into the
Marvel Universe
and that's why the first Hulk movie was
made in 2008 because by making one film
we got the rights back for Hulk and
perpetuity
at least as a supporting character
and also we were splitting toys 50 50
with universal and that became way in
our favor and Hulk hands were our number
one toy so we were thinking of Hulk
potentially as the first movie
and then Iron Man came back and Kevin
and I were both really excited about
Iron Man as was Javier Rod who was still
at the studio he left in early 2006. and
so we zeroed in on that I don't know
exactly why other people missed it I
think we were excited about was the man
inside the suit like we love the sexy
suit of armor like most people do but
Tony Stark is such a cool character and
if you don't see Tony Stark you don't
see how good the movie can be and so I
think that was probably the Breakthrough
for the three of us
yeah I can't remember which film it was
from but
one of the Marvel films I think it was
quite a bit later where there's some
disagreement I thought I want to say
it's between Thor and Stark and he's
like well if we take that suit off you
who are you and he's like billionaire
playboy exactly
oh God what a character yeah all right
let's then walk into
the next steps for Iron Man because I
feel like this is such a
maybe not make it or break it but just
such a critical
project overall as sort of a harbinger
of things to come perhaps as a signal as
a proof of concept
what were some of the key decisions or
critical moments
in that development phase and then
moving into the theatrical release
to give perspective on that we talked
about how in 2004 2005 it was primarily
raising the money and getting
distribution partner in Paramount
I was then promoted the vice chairman of
the studio
in that period
and in 2006 Avi left the studio and then
I was running the studio myself and I
promoted Kevin feige who was a young kid
that was helping Avi on script notes who
I'd gotten to know very well and admired
him his creativity and his love of the
comics I promoted him to be my president
of production and I was chairman of the
studio and promoted to that
I also was fortunate to be promoted to
Office of the CEO with Ike and John of
the parent company right and so it's
relevant because
with those pieces in place we were able
to focus solely on making that film
right there was no more internal
politics there wasn't these external
things we needed like financing or
distribution deals we had that we had
the rights back we had a clean structure
in the company
and I promoted my ex assistant
into the creative realm he became our
number two guy creatively Jeremy latcham
we hire Ludy Esposito and Victoria
Alonso to amazing talents
early in that period of time and
all of us then focused on making this
movie
John Favre was identified as the
Director and Robert Downey as the actor
that was the two big decisions how did
those two end up happening a lot of
people think of John today for his Star
Wars stuff and a lot of visual effects
but at the time he was well more known
for for swingers and you know for those
types of films people forget about elf
too yeah he was just coming off as the
Thora
and we knew we felt like we knew how to
do the comic book part of things like
the action and the comic bookie part of
stuff but we also knew we didn't have a
lot of money to make the movie I could
green light to 165 million but I I told
my board I'd make the film at a budget
that would allow it to break even at a
percentage I think two-thirds of of
X-Men and so my budget for the film was
about 105 million dollars now that's
sounds like a lot but it wasn't I mean
Batman that year was 230 million
and so that allowed us to have
some action but not a lot so we knew
we'd have an hour and 45 minutes of you
know Tony Stark in his Workshop or
talking to Pepper pots
and John was great on those scenes and
is great on those scenes and also
getting the best out of talent like
Robert Downey so I think that was
something we all saw in favro plus he
seemed very committed to it
his career obviously has taken off
in the past 15 years tremendously and
he's shown his talent in so many other
other ways
and Robert Downey I think originally
came from from John and Kevin they both
were proponents for Robert a studio
chairman I had to give the final thumbs
up and thumbs down on that but I agreed
with them
knowing Tony Stark from the comics and
Robert's work you know it wasn't obvious
I mean Robert had never had a box office
success he had just been arrested a
couple years earlier for for drugs oh
and spend time in jail so it's not who
you bet your company on you know and he
came in and did a video audition which
is also rare and I remember taking that
recommendation to Ike and the board and
showing him that video audition
and
they asked a lot of tough questions
but they also agreed and that was that
was a key part I mean I think with those
two pieces in place Kevin and I were Off
to the Races with John and Robert to
make this film which is I think this
month you know it's our 15th anniversary
of release
wow
what were some of the biggest challenges
it could have been in production or in
distribution or in any facet of that
experience what I just talked you
through was the biggest Tim it was
getting the job at Marvel getting the
financing in place convincing the board
getting distribution deal
getting the rights back to Iron Man
getting the board to agree with us on
Robert Downey
and getting the internal politics of
Marvel like there are in every company
settled so by that spring of 2006 two
years before the movie comes out we have
all those pieces in place
and we didn't have an office we took the
Mercedes-Benz dealership in Santa Monica
Boulevard
Playboy had an office in the very top
corner and they were having financial
difficulties and I sublet it from Hefner
and put a Marvel studio sign outside
that cost ten thousand dollars
and we announced our presence and we
just would work there 18 hours a day
we moved pre-production for a movie
which is where all the planning gets
done right there in that same floor
which is normally never done with the
studio which was Kevin and I
but I guess there's another thing that
people should hear about is I had this
philosophy that Studios
Hollywood Studios
were had this unnecessary layer of
management called Studio Executives who
hired the producers so I our model was
there's no Studio Executives we were the
producers of the movie and so Kevin and
I were technically Studio Executives but
we were you know working on the film
Kevin every day me with a significant
chunk of my time because I was also a
co-ceo
and we didn't have that layer so we all
with John and Robert and all the
pre-production were all together for
months you know planning out this film
we had a pretty smooth ride you know
amazingly from that point on we took the
Spruce Goose hanger by the ocean where
Howard Hughes had this huge wooden
hanger that he built the biggest
airplane in the world and that's you
know appropriately where we filmed it
since Tony Stark is influenced by Howard
Hughes
and you know it was a big decision
because we didn't get tax incentives by
being in California
but it turned out to be great because we
were all so close
and it became a set of people that were
really enthusiastic one of the Paltrow
joined that was a big win I think it was
Brian Lord who called me and said
Gwyneth was interested and my God to get
an academy award-winning actress like
her you know it was a dream
so it all came together
we had some disagreements at the end
about reshoots which cost some money
but I was able to get Ike and the board
to approve the ones that we wanted to do
but marketing was a tough challenge too
to get Paramount to manage marketing
because all this stuff doesn't make any
sense if nobody goes to see the movie
and I think it was katzenberg who told
me to show up at every meeting and you
know that make sure we get a good
release date
in retrospect we chose May 2nd
because nobody else wanted it like it
was an early date
people thought this Summer started with
Memorial Day and so us going to May 2nd
now it's a great date and Marvel has it
every year but we had it it turned out
to be really good because we had the
first movie of the summer
and Paramount gave us that date they
keep their best dates for their own
movies so we were able to get a date
they didn't want
it sounds weird to say things went
smoothly from that point on but for
those two years things went very
smoothly
let me rewind just a little bit because
I have some notes in front of me that I
want to fact check with you yeah
and this you can't believe everything
you read on the internet but this is
Hollywood Reporter so you would hope
that it is accurate yes is it true that
you had an early proof of concept in the
sense of changing Marvel strategy with a
low budget Iron Man animated film or
maybe animatics is that true yeah it is
in 2004 while I was raising the money
for the theatrical films I wanted to
prove to the board that we actually
could produce something
and so I was able to make a deal with
Lionsgate Michael Burns and John
feldheimer who still run Lionsgate
that we'd make three million dollar
directed DVD animated movies I think the
budget was three to four million and
they put up the money
we at from Marvel Studios produced we
hired a guy named Eric Roman for those
who aren't watching the video that was
air quotes in that example yeah I
remember they got their 4 million back
when we split the money so we had no
risk it was like a mini Marvel Studios
type of deal and we made I forget the
order we made it Doctor Strange one we
made Iron Man we made Avengers we made a
Hulk one and they all did pretty well
and so they're still fun to watch that
was our chance to creatively be in
charge of a project and show the board
that we could do it yeah incredible a
lot of people don't point that out to
him you do good research yeah well I
need to thank my team also for finding
this particular example and
I
love finding these proof of concept
moments or talking as we have been also
about structuring because as you
mentioned I think in many worlds not
just film not just Hollywood
There is almost a religious divide
between the the people who are
derisively called suits and the people
who are sometimes over romanticized as
creatives and you can be
a sort of one event
athlete in that sense that you stick
really narrowly within a lane and you
can become world class and very
successful doing that but in many cases
it's like the creatives don't get to do
what they would most want to do unless
things are structured by someone who
understands incentives and these various
Provisions right so it's I find your
story so compelling for a lot of reasons
one of which is you blend
these capacities in a very effective way
because they could be Blended
ineffectively yeah right part of it Tim
is
I think most people because I haven't
done press
they view my role as very much the
financial structuring the distribution
deal the co-ceo role on Marvel and less
on the creative side and
I think in retrospect and talking this
through with you the biggest creative
thing I've ever done in my life was the
first that weekend and having the vision
for the MCU for having what became the
universe and just intuitively believing
these characters could become a modern
mythology for this world and that's a
delusional belief I had at the time in
in retrospect like I didn't realize the
bar of this and then I had to put on the
hat that I had to do for each of the
dominoes you know so if I went into my
board and I just creatively talked
they wouldn't have listened to me right
so I had to argue in their language
about finance and to the bankers about
the financing and to Paramount about
their breakevens
and politically structure a studio in
terms of personnel that I thought could
do well and
and then to manage creative people like
John Favreau and Robert Downey and Kevin
feige my president of production who
they all worked for me right I was
chairman of the studio I'm you know so
but to get the best out of them it's
I learned this from my time at CA in
Disney right it it can't be because
you're their boss it's got to be because
you give them the creative freedom to
explore and
be careful about guard rails right so
a lot of people would say oh it was my
idea I was Studio chairman to do Robert
Dowdy rather than saying yeah I mean
John and Kevin recommended him right
and I love that I mean that's why you
hire good people that's why I prom I'm
very proud of promoting Kevin feige a
lot of people I think believe
because I haven't been doing press that
Stan Lee or Kevin
created Marvel Studios
and
as we heard in the story
that's not the case right there's the
Baton came to me and that was my legacy
which I'm really proud of I'm also
really proud of identifying Kevin and I
remember the conversation with like who
had never met Kevin before in 2006
likes in New York and Kevin and I were
in LA
though you need to hire somebody when
Avi left I said no Kevin can do it he
could be my president in production and
he's now when I sold the company to
Disney I told the same thing the Iger
that Kevin could run it and he's become
I'm his biggest fan in how he's done the
films the past 10 years and you know has
become
the most respected creative producer in
Hollywood and so part of managing
creativity
is knowing when to exert yours and when
to get the best out from others I
remember the biggest time I ever exerted
mine
was early in 2006
I think was over Christmas holidays
I got unhappy with the Iron Man script
and
the script at the time Jeff Bridges
Obadiah stain who in the movie is the
villain was actually working for the
Mandarin
and and so there was a whole nother
scene or two where we met the Mandarin
in China and he was manipulating Obadiah
stain and there was another big action
sequence and that felt too comic Booky
to me because for these movies to work I
was running marketing from Marvel's
perspective I didn't delegate that I was
going to every meeting as the chairman
of Marvel Studios I had the relationship
with Rob Moore to get the best out of
Paramount Kevin was on set every day
and so we would talk about everything of
course and I'd go to set many times and
Kevin would come to marketing meetings
but we needed to appeal from a marketing
point of view to non-comic book fans
otherwise we would have died like only
four or five thousand people read Iron
Man Comics so I needed the movie to be
appealing to my mom my girlfriend at the
time you know the whole world and so it
had to be a classic story about a man
changing his life who happened to change
into being a superhero
and making other big decisions and so my
my Spidey Sense was the story was
getting too comic Booky in act three
and we needed to make it more
Shakespearean where the father figure of
Obadiah was the villain and so I went in
a studio chairman where I could have
dictated that and told John Favreau and
Kevin were chopping off that part of the
movie but instead I went in I remember
first calling Ike and John and telling
them
what I thought about in my discomfort
and then going in and calling a meeting
and recommending it and explaining why
to John into Kevin and to the team
rather than just ordering it
and to their credit they embraced it
pretty quickly and that became which we
had to do because we were pretty close
to getting to production
and that I think made the story we all
believed better we kept the Mandarin for
a later film and we saved money on the
budget too because we didn't have to do
that scene we probably didn't piss off
China at the time so we had a lot of
benefits from that decision win-win-win
so I don't know Robert Downey Jr I don't
know Kevin but I have spent some time
with John he's been on the podcast and I
just want to strongly plus one
that he is
one of the most talented people and
that's not to diminish the hard work
that goes into it I should say skilled
people on a multitude of levels that I
have met and really knows how to do what
you were describing in terms of
embracing the comedy but not making it
overly
slapstick yeah and getting a lot out of
performances on screen he's really
really exceptional and also just very
very at least in all of my experiences
just a very pleasant guy to be around he
is we had a blast on set and the other
thing John did really well to your point
there is we didn't freeze the script on
Iron Man which meant which most people
would say is crazy because each day
costs three or five hundred thousand
depending on the day of cost so if you
miss your day and you don't finish
everything you you blow that money
but we kept time for Robert to improvise
and John managed that and Kevin and they
did a great job and John is the director
and so many of the lines that you
probably love that so many people love
came out of Robert improvising you know
and that was a risk and
I felt very secure in that given John's
expertise like you say worked out so
let's look at the series of events and
I'd love for you to walk us through the
Milestones or the
key moments between Iron Man and the
sail to Disney
before we get to that I have to ask
because you've mentioned it a few times
why so quiet with PR why haven't you
done more PR
it relates to what you're about to ask
me to sail to Disney which I try to live
life intentionally and
one of the things that I've tried to
avoid is
to get too focused on my own I guess ego
for lack of a better word and so
one of the reasons I sold the company to
Disney
one big reason was shareholder value and
get the best price and the other was me
personally I was okay with it because I
wanted to venture away and do new
challenges and we can get back to that
but I realized that if I open the door
on the pr side
it would just be a route that didn't
interest me at the time and I'd be
talking about the past all the time and
I fortunately did well with the sales of
Marvel to Disney and so obviously I
could have afford PR people and I just
never did that
and that was my reason I just thought it
was unnecessary
I didn't realize Tim at the time as a
different discussion I always thought
truth always prevailed and you know
we've learned in a lot of parts of our
lives in the past you know eight years
that that truth is fungible and so
it was something where
by being quiet there was a lot of
confusion about all the stuff that we
talked about and I found my story
essentially being somewhat Rewritten out
of History which is really weird when
it's
you know eight years of your life and
something that was your vision and dream
to the point of Articles being written
where they just didn't even mention what
we just talked about
and one famously in the cover of Vanity
Fair a few years ago
and the same author of that article is
writing a book that's coming out in the
history of Marvel Studios coming out in
November Joanna Robinson
who now has done her research and knows
the story that we've talked through
and realizes the mistake that they made
so the past couple years I've realized
two things I mean one
I enjoy telling the story it's a big
part of who I am my friends knew people
like Brian Lord and Kevin Vain and my
Hollywood friends knew and the people in
Hollywood that mattered
but even in many cases if they don't see
it written and so on it gets confusing
so I've realized that
if you care about something it's
important to be part of the narrative
luckily for Marvel it's so big and has
done so well that there's plenty of
shine to share you know yeah as I
mentioned
Avi I give him full credit for the
license deals of which I would not have
been able to
open some of the doors I did
and Kevin I'm his biggest fan but I'm
proud of my vision for Marvel Studios
and where it came from me and whether
it's my future wife or it's people
listening to this podcast that's part of
who I am I'm proud of going there and
making it happen and putting on all
those different hats that we talked
about that were needed at the time and
I'm proud of handing the Baton to Kevin
and and the sale to Disney
and so there's enough
great
credit for everybody to have
and hopefully everybody sees that once
all the facts come out
you know this is a big step in in
talking about PR and it's fun to tell a
story to people there's so many
different angles to it and the other
part that's been a big influence is when
my mom was recently sick a lot of the
doctors and nurses and other people
around her
I'd have time with and I would tell them
the story and I realized how it affected
their lives like they'd go home and tell
their kids they're with the guy who
founded Marvel Studios and and not
everyone gets to
you know meet us and have these
discussions and I realized
Marvel brings a lot of joy in people's
lives
I just flew back from Miami yesterday
and I have a Marvel bag with me and the
security guy you know at the airport
was all excited you know and he helped
me through security which was a good
benefit so there's actually a selfish
benefit of carrying a Marvel bag
Pro tip go get some marble bags
I'm really glad that
that you're willing to take the time to
have this conversation I'm having a lot
of fun I'm learning a lot I'm taking
notes
not only about your entire Journey with
Marvel but I'm gonna watch all that jazz
and there's more of course in the notes
but let's let's talk about Iron Man to
sail and you can walk us through that in
any way that makes sense
and I'll I'll leave it to you to guide
us
so as we're making the film I mentioned
that things went smoothly from Spring of
2006 to May 2nd 2008.
they didn't really go smoothly in terms
of people's perception of the movie they
went smoothly in us making it us feeling
good about it but nobody really believed
our stock went down for four and a half
years so I game in my options were 19
bucks a share when Iron Man came out I
think the stock was traded like 18 a
share so and I was not for lack of
trying I mean I was on CNBC you know
touting marvel
Ike famously doesn't really care about
press but even he agreed we should do
press and so we had articles and
business week at the time and Fortune
and financial times and all these other
places New York Times as well a famous
article that I keep by my office door
which talks about all the risks about
Marvel this was like a 2006 or 2007
article at the end of the article I'm
like David's you know we're doing this
really in smart creative way and people
are going to love it it sounded like I
was crazy on the street you know
so even Paramount projected we're gonna
do about 40 or 50 million for the
weekend and my board
came finally to La they didn't care
about it really too much like from that
point of view but we had the premiere
and
I remember my board
telling me that Kevin and I would get I
think it was a half a million dollar
bonus each if the film broke even
and so that was my own company was like
Hey attaboy the way to go break Steven
will make money on the toys you know and
so it wasn't like there was I think we
were immune to it I think
Kevin and I and and I think John and
Robert we were so immersed in making the
movie and we felt so good about it that
for some reason that lack of confidence
in the Wall Street or otherwise didn't
affect us too much but it was there it's
important to realize that because
I was having lunch with Bob Iger
probably once a year since I joined and
Kevin Mayer and I'd wear my Spider-Man
tie and stuff like that
but it was only after Iron Man came out
did I really start thinking
where does this company go and we had
Hulk coming out a month later and that
film a lot of people misunderstand
they're like wondering why we did it and
like I said we did it to get the rights
back for Hulk as a supporting character
in movies like The Avengers
and we had to make that movie for that
and we planned the budget of that movie
to do break even as long as it did like
the first film so we weren't expecting
it to
break out like Iron Man did
but the night Iron Man came out I was at
a man named Ron berkle's house
who had become a mentor and still is and
I got a phone call
from Rob Moore that at like 6 p.m hey
we're gonna do 60 million and like hour
later 70 million every hour went up 10
million finally it had 100 million at
like 10 p.m at night on Friday night and
I knew
you know things had changed from Marvel
they changed for John Robert Kevin and I
what a night can I just pause to say or
actually pause to ask like what did that
feel like what was your experience as
you're getting these updates hour by
hour
it was by the way it's still unreal like
telling the story to you
like I still pinch myself every day that
I was able to go from Reading Iron Man
Comics to like having this crazy dream
to making Marvel
into what it is today is crazy and
kids ask me how do you do that you know
I just don't even like it's just it
doesn't happen right and so
when Iron Man came out and we knew the
number the adrenaline was just huge like
we had just had the premiere people
seemed buzzed about it but until we got
that box office number you get really
busy like you have to give quotes right
away and we had and a Wall Street
analyst meeting coming up like that next
Tuesday
and so you get busy doing things but
I probably didn't really celebrate it
until later in the summer you know
we did have a dinner this year people
might be interested in so I organized a
dinner at Mr Chows famous restaurant in
LA
in Beverly Hills with John Favre Robert
Downey Kevin and myself to celebrate and
it was like
a couple weeks after Iron Man opened and
Kevin and I had suggested to Ike that we
buy cars for Robert and John as presents
for them and we had worked with their
wives to figure out what cars they want
and so Favreau had picked this Mercedes
and Robert Bentley and so at Mr Chows we
swapped favreau's car so he drove in
with whatever old car he had and we knew
he's going to get his Mercedes and we
brought Robert in on the joke
so I'll come back to that in a second
but at dinner we celebrated and I said
guys I will green light Iron Man 2 if
everyone around this table and I looked
at John and Robert and Kevin commit to
making it so we can release it May 2nd
2010 or whatever the equivalent weekend
was which is really quick for a movie
with no script and I think everyone was
sort of surprised right and things don't
just happen that way in Hollywood so a
lot of what we did in this movie was
like Film School like I mean Natalie
Portman I was introduced to by Leo
DiCaprio
we wanted Natalie to be in Thor she had
no desire Kevin vane was her agent
to really be in it and then he knew I
wanted her in the movie and he was
bowling with her one night and texted me
to get dressed and come out to a
midnight bowling in Hollywood and he
introduced me to her and
said you two should work together and so
it was really like kids in film School
so it all worked out for everybody so we
did celebrate and then at the end of
that night
we gave John his new car but the
funniest part was Robert was in on the
joke but there was no car for him and we
did that on purpose so that he'd get
like where the hell's my car in his mind
right and so we waited a week so he'd be
like wondering oh brutal brutal yeah
his wife told us when he was taking a
nap one afternoon and we brought it into
his driveway so when he woke up he saw
it in his driveway which was fun that's
incredible that's so fun so we had fun
with it a bit yeah so you mentioned
these regular meals I think it was with
Bob Iger and then you mentioned Ron
Berkel who's become and still is a
mentor yep I want to pick up on those
two what was the context of meeting with
Bob on a regular basis was it's just to
keep in touch to swap stories
to give news from the front lines in
your respective worlds what was the
context
and then stepping back for your audience
it wasn't just having meals like I
called Bob a couple times with business
proposals
one of the time I said let's do animated
movies 50 50. Marvel Disney
and that didn't go anywhere we had a
habit of talking about business
opportunities
but our stock was so low in February of
2009 that I didn't raise a sale at all
and then importantly and this is all
public because when you do things as a
public company the SEC makes you go back
for five years every email every meeting
every communication I had with Bob or
with Kevin Mayer or anybody else at
Disney is is public record
I called Bob in end of May our stock was
back up to 35. I felt that Disney stock
was also undervalued it was at 25 a
share with the economic collapse and
Disney
as a company is very sensitive to the
economy people go to theme parks more
often they do stuff like that
and so I felt like I was a big Disney
shareholder that Disney or I follow this
stock closely at least that Disney was
at least a double when the economy
recovered whereas we were at two movies
a year at best and could be plateaued
for a while and and Dreamworks Animation
was a company that also had two movies a
year and they were plateaued so all of
that in my mind I when I saw her stock
hit 35 or 36 or 37 I called Bob we
organized a secret meeting in his office
for early June I brought my Marvel
Encyclopedia of characters with me and
and that's the meeting where this is
news for your listeners there was two
deals that we had on the table that
would have encumbered us and cumbering
means we would have tied up our rights
and been way less attractive for a
potential purchaser we were about to
extend our distribution deal on the
movies
beyond what Paramount had to another
Studio I won't name them on this on this
thing yet but
we were very close to doing like another
10 or 20 movies to them
and we were about to do a kids TV
network with Discovery in Hasbro which
ended up being called the Hub
so I remember David zazlov at the time
and and Brian goldner the CEO of Hasbro
recently passed away the three of us
were working on this and I was working
on this other deal so I knew that there
was a window to sell the company that
six months later we'd be way less
attractive to Disney or anyone else
because we'd be committed to somebody
else in TV and somebody else in film
and I was gun shy I knew how easily a
deal can fall apart from my previous
time suggesting this at Disney so all of
that was in my mind in June when I went
to see Bob and I remember telling Bob
about our TV deal and with Discovery in
Hasbro and him saying hold on let's do a
TV deal at Disney we'll do a primarily
mail but you know kids teenager
Entertainment Network and
and I joked with him I said no you know
not going to get a little bit pregnant
we either do something big or we don't
and he took that
to his credit and said then let's think
something big
and I remember vividly I said I think we
would need fifty dollars a share we need
a five in front of it so we went pretty
far in this meeting and he knew I knew
Kevin Mayer and he knew I knew Tom
Staggs who was CFO at the time
I think and he basically said well my
board and Kevin and Tom think that's a
fair price and I said absolutely I said
I've got this thing planned out for the
next 10 years
and so since I had done work for Bob he
I think had some trust in that
and we talked about the vision of
connecting all the characters and what
the future movies were going to be Iron
Man 2 was our next movie
we had delayed Thor so I knew that would
be good to have Iron Man 2 is the next
movie because that's predictable
and I explained how we're leading up to
the Avengers and how everything after
Iron Man would be a sequel to Iron Man
everything after Avengers a sequel to
Avengers
which I think has proved to be the case
and
that was first week of June 2009 we
announced the deal the end of August two
months later and we kept it secret
and they ended up paying I think it was
51 a share and we got 40 percent of it
in Disney stock we wanted 50 percent
and so that was a great trade for our
shareholders
and turned out to be one and you know
Disney got up to 180 or 200 at some
point now there's close to 100.
even with their correction
and so I remember meeting with Kevin
Mayer right after that we didn't even
have a banker and
I went through my projections with Kevin
and his friends we yelled at each other
sword each other
all that kind of stuff I remember Kevin
saying I was basically saying
for Captain America and Thor you need to
give us credit for like 80 percent of
Iron Man
you know in your model and he's like no
it should be 60 no one cares about those
characters whatever and so and then I
said Iron Man 2 should be like 110 of
Iron Man and Avengers should be like 150
of Iron Man he's like no Avengers is a
new movie like that should be like
Captain America or Thor
and I was like no iron you know Robert
Downey we had signed up for the Avengers
so it's basically a quasi Iron Man
sequel so all those things were like
it's an interesting story because I'm
negotiating with someone I worked with
that I've known for decades
with a company where I worked at
intimately
to your question though
after that first meeting I went to that
meeting
I didn't even know I was having a
and if he didn't know he would not be
surprised because it would be about a
business deal like you know any that
kind of stuff I called Ike from in front
of Team Disney
after leaving Bob and I and I was as
pumped about this meeting as I was about
Iron Man's box office
because I could see the excitement of
Bob's eyes
it turns out that they had internally
been reviewing options and Marvel was on
their list though they hadn't
proactively contacted anybody including
myself and I called Ike and I told him I
think I have a buyer for the company and
I thought there would be one of three
responses Tim
even though Iron Man it came out even
though it was my idea to do the MCU or
Marvel this new Marvel Studios
self-financed self-producing and
connecting the characters I want to come
back in a second but even with all that
I knew Ike might say you're fired right
on the spot
or more likely get your ass back to the
office and work on Iron Man 2 and other
initiatives that we were doing as a
company
but he said fly to New York
come see me and
I made a reservation to come right away
like the next morning or whatever and I
rode on the airplane what my scenario
planning would be
so he was open-minded to it once I got
there and made the case
wow okay so you didn't Lop your head off
no didn't March you off with the guards
yeah I mean that seems to speak volumes
to his
character and presence of mind to be
able to
mentally having
committed for so long to not selling nor
even entertaining the possibility of a
sale
to
endure the cognitive dissonance of
considering it as an option I mean
that's that's no small feat I think
that's a trade I saw and Ike all the way
through he's notorious for being very
fiscally conservative and some people
mistake that for not being supportive of
major decisions and he did hire me and
gave me a chance with Marvel Studios and
here he gave me a chance he still wasn't
convinced but he at least wanted to hear
my case yeah and um it took a while to
convince him and then the major thing
was
Bob and Ike had to get together and so
in the meeting with Bob I remember Bob
said what do we need to do I even even
asked me what do you want out of this
David and I said no no you have to make
Ike happy like that's the person that
has to be convinced
and I had basically you know understood
from Bob that
if I didn't want to do something that
that this wouldn't go anywhere
and
so I arranged a meeting in New York
where Bob came to the offices at like
nine o'clock at night and he and Ike I
let them go to dinner I kept back and I
didn't ask to go and and they had a
wonderful dinner and
I think this is public Bob had Steve
Jobs call Ike and talk to him how well
Bob preserved Pixar's culture after the
sale so all of that really helped you
know get this across the Finish Line
incredible what a story wow what a what
a wild adventure how does Ron Burkle fit
in as your mentor
in all of this Rob's been a mentor and a
dear friend and it's and maybe just in a
snapshot explain just enough
background so that people can sort of
conjure an image of someone Ron is most
famous for owning Ralph's grocery stores
he started as a bagger and became the
owner and became a billionaire through
that in other Investments and he's
notorious as a very Savvy investor and a
very hard businessman to you know in
terms of the terms that he requests for
Investments and
we met
I don't know exactly where we met but I
think we met at one point when he was
interested in buying Endeavor when I was
working with Ari in the early days
and that deal didn't go anywhere but Ron
and I
became friends and then he watched my
career
at Marvel and the relationship grew
deeper he also he had Leo as a mutual
friend
and so we had social acquaintances in
common as well
but the intersection with the Marvel
story is I was at his house for a party
that night when the when the box office
came out the night before Ironman came
out we actually Kevin and Robert and
John and I went to theaters together to
see the Thursday night shows and that
was a blast because it was the first
time we saw a live audience watching the
films we didn't test Market these movies
at all that was exciting we wanted
Robert to sell tickets but they wouldn't
let us have him do that why didn't you
test Market I'm curious so no test
audiences it's very atypical we could
have really blown this Tim we went a lot
with our instincts the collective group
and
I'm trying to remember if we ever had
one I don't recall it happening no
wow so you mentioned the dinner
the the Turning Point dinner with Bob
and Ike and then a lesser-known fellow
named Steve Jobs calling Ike right to
talk about Pixar
and then we know how that story in a
sense ends at least from the public
perspective which is in the successful
acquisition are there any other points
along that path that you would like to
mention or fill in
I think from a deal perspective besides
negotiating the percentage in Disney
stock we were pretty close to what Bob
and I spoke to in that first meeting and
then it became about keeping Marvel as a
separate company within Disney so the
culture didn't get messed up and I
specifically wanted to step aside
and I
introduced I told Bob about Kevin how I
thought he could run the Marvel entity
within Disney in a uniquely great way
and then I've got to meet Kevin and and
see for himself and so that was a big
part because personally
I wanted to go on to different Ventures
and different parts of my life and
selling to Disney allowed me to do that
in a very clean way both financially
with other shareholders to be able to
afford that and then too easier to leave
a company when it's a division of a
bigger company than by itself so that
for me was personally in addition to the
deal time it was sort of exciting to
think about my next venture and scary
because I didn't quite know who I was
outside of my role at Marvel
and what that person would be
and so but besides that the deal went
through pretty well
and
you know the price of it we got four
billion dollars
which is about 3.8 billion more than the
price when I joined and
we ran a lot of scenarios when I
presented to the board in 2004 but the
the main scenario valued the new studio
as potentially in the three to four
billion dollar range and it came out
close enough to that
and you know our comic division
and other things had not really grown
too much our our toy division we went
from making toys to licensing which was
sounds like a minor thing but it was big
at the time
but pretty much it was
a lot of people now I guess are hearing
Marvel Studios was a startup within the
parent company of Marvel but it was one
that had to raise its own money it got
the IP from the parent company
but other than that we had to manage it
raise our own money do our own deals and
I was speaking to a tech entrepreneur
this past weekend in Florida from one of
the biggest tech companies in the world
and
he was very intrigued about how Marvel
Studios was a startup just like his
company was at the time
and so hopefully that's interesting to a
lot of people that are hearing this
so David I think this may be a logical
place to begin to wind to a close with
this first chapter of our ongoing
conversation and I I want to do a bit of
teasing so next time there's lots I
would want to talk about but broadly
speaking I'd want to talk about some of
your adventures outside of Marvel and
Disney so angry birds and other things
including
ecosgenesis which we will talk about at
some length
and also how people might think about
building
a universe constructing a universe of
characters
what are the necessary steps common
mistakes Etc that that you might be able
to share as Lessons Learned or things
observed
and I would say I'll ask you one of my
two of my favorites
rapid fire questions the answers don't
need to be rapid fire but the the
questions are intended to be short
because I can be very long-winded with
my like 17 part questions
this lead up is an example of that
so the first question is
what books if any have you gifted the
most to other people or recommended the
most
that come to mind or gifted a lot or
recommended a lot to other people are
there any books that come to mind
I might have to think about that for the
next session yep we can come back to it
you know the book I recommend to people
the most is Stranger in a Strange Land
by Robert Heinlein such a good book I'm
not sure that's really it counts yeah
that's a classic it's an Incredible Book
it's probably the live action movie I
would most like to make as an individual
movie you know
that could be interesting all right let
me ask you maybe a close cousin of a
question which is not one of my rapid
fire but yeah are there any properties
caricatures
stories that you're not thinking of
pursuing yourself that you just hope
someone excellent out there makes into a
film or some type of immersive World
outside of its original format
I love how you said film or some other
type of immersive world I think that's
very Savvy by the way and we can get
into that in the next discussion because
I don't believe launching the next
universe is going to happen like Marvel
did through theatrical film I think it's
going to start with something else
and
and most likely will because of the way
the world has changed and so I think the
question in the topic as a tease for
this next thing when I left Marvel I had
to figure out who I was from a person
point of view like with people still
want to talk to me if I wasn't running
Marvel Studios right
would I still be able to go to
restaurants and things like that
who my real friends were and then from a
business point of view what would catch
my eye and what I'd say is because
of Marvel within Disney and the power of
the two together and because of how well
Kevin has run Marvel since
Marvel's gotten so big that the bar to
launch in the universe has gotten so
high and so much tougher because now
you're competing against Marvel right so
when I launched in 2008 Iron Man
we had DC as a competitor we had the
Marvel licensed movies you know Fox with
X-Men Sony with Spider-Man they could
they were not just competitors they
could use the Marvel Grand so they were
like weird competitors we were scared
about all these people but in retrospect
we had a relatively open playing field
because we didn't have ourselves to
compete with the version of Marvel today
which just dominates so much and we
didn't have streaming we didn't have as
much social media all these other
distractions on people's time and
you know it was tough but it's like you
know it's the old saying like how good
we had it you know we didn't realize
still very tough but now it's even
harder so something that goes through
the filter you're talking about
has to be pretty special to pop into
what you would call Universe category or
major potentially new mythology
and I'd love to talk about that more
because it is something that a lot of
people do ask about
and a lot of people are focused on
obviously DC just hired a new person to
run DC after 15 years or 20 years of of
us being able to do what we did in
Marvel they're David zazlov when he
bought Warner Brothers from atnc said I
want to copy Marvel I want to do what
Marvel did
but we did that 15 20 years ago so it
shows you even DC hasn't gotten their
act together in the same way and that's
a very well capitalized company with a
large number of properties so you know
it's it's very hard
for
a new universe to get created I don't
think it's impossible
but it's got to be differentiated from
Marvel so that there's a reason that it
exists I think it has to be introduced
in new ways that you sort of tease
with new technologies and new ways of
Storytelling probably has to be way more
primal
and visual so it gets
you know people's quick attention they
can see what's there I think it has to
have great meaning to him
Marvel had a good meaning in that it's
great to be a hero
and I think people relate to something
that
they feel is adding to their lives and
somehow whether they sense it or it's
just subconscious
that's what all mythologies from Greek
and Roman onward have done or before
even Greek and Roman mythology
and it has to be something I think
I think listen
James Cameron with Avatar has probably
done the best since Marvel came out with
big cultural moments now he does things
every 10 years though right but that was
an original idea I think the next thing
probably
is a legacy property but it's still like
Marvel it had history but people could
Discover it together so it was the
perfect combination
and I think people love to discover
something with their friends and the
idea of the new band or something in new
technology like there's just something
great you know I hear you and Kevin
talking on podcasts and like two friends
discovering things together whether it
be pipe smoking or whether it be
something else and it's like yeah but
there's something fun like pipe smoking
is a good example that's a legacy
activity that we understand our
grandparents did and people before them
but it still felt new when you talked
about it with Kevin you know and Marvel
was Legacy but for most people they
never read the comics it was new for
them to talk with their friends did you
see Iron Man did you see all that it's
like the youngsters these days running
around with Nirvana shirts on I mean
it's there's really been this Resurgence
of grunge popularity I'm like wow didn't
see that coming that's wild yeah and if
there's no Legacy then it's just purely
new like you can't you don't get into
like the geekiness of like with pipes
how was it done 100 years ago and look
at this pipe is collectible or whatever
ever you know like you don't have all
that and if it's completely Legacy but
it's so big then there's no thrill of
Discovery right so it's the balance on
the scale of those things you know I
think did a really nice job this is
within serial television but stranger
things because they were tapping into
all of these hot button passions from
decades ago
but at layering on top of that
novel story lines I thought it was
executed extremely well I haven't
watched Beyonce season one but I I
thought wow that's a really smart
combination in how they approach that so
I think we just answered the question
about new universes by comparing it to
pipe smoking
the questions
I'm gonna skip my other question I'll
save it for next time which is the
Billboard question I'll advise you in
advance so
that you have some heads up but is there
anything else you would like to add
before we come to a close anything else
you'd like to make a request of the
audience comment recommendation
philosophical note or two anything at
all I appreciate that and I will think
about that also for part two but I think
we went into a lot of details about how
what happened in 2003 through the sale
to Disney in 2010 whether it be
financing or distribution or the sale
and I think stepping back for a second
there was also a simple
pursuit of
something you really believed in and
that you're passionate about and when I
think to myself
you know what happens if I didn't go to
Marvel or if I didn't take that meeting
or didn't hire me or if I took the
Michael Michael Jackson didn't get
arrested thank God for the timing on
that one not being halfway through that
you know the butterfly effect of
no new Marvel Studios for Disney to have
for no Avengers movie because one of the
things we didn't talk about is
if the movies are all licensed at
different Studios they never get mixed
together so to create Avengers to mix
the characters we had to own and keep
the rights ourselves
and so just legally these characters
would never be mixed together and there
wouldn't be this interrelated universe
and and the ripple effect and everything
else is so big and I I do think as
people think about their lives and they
think about their decisions you know we
all have that butterfly effect somehow
you know almost every day on decisions
we make and that might not be as evident
as no Avengers movie or something as big
culturally
but it's exciting to realize that your
life has that potential
in your own personal life you know you
and your focus on health had a butterfly
effect on me getting healthy recently in
these past six months and and a mutual
friend hearing that story and
introducing us right
so even this podcast comes from that
chance event happening and
I think that's one of the big lessons
from that that even if you are just with
your family or your friends like the
effect of your actions and everything
else does create all these cool things
in life and it creates wonder and awe
about what life can be and sometimes you
know real passion and sort of Dreams can
become reality and
in this crazy world that we live in
that's probably the biggest sentiment I
can say to people
what a great place to wrap up also here
here so thank you David makes me want to
get out there get after it or just sit
down and do some doodling because you
just never know where it's gonna go
that's true and these huge things often
start off just as a glimmer
in some handful of neurons and then
look at where that's LED what a wild
story
and people can find you I'll link to all
these in the show notes but on social
and other places I can find you on
Twitter at
maiseldavid that's spelled m-a-i-s-e-l
David d-a-v-i-d you they can find ecos
Genesis at ecos Genesis on Twitter ekos
Genesis from Bluemont a preview of part
of what we'll be discussing next time
and the website for that is ekos dot i o
and so nice to spend time with you David
I really appreciate you blocking out the
time to have this conversation I feel
the same it's been a pleasure uh talking
through this stuff and um
I look forward to part two yeah more to
come more to come and for everybody
listening as always we will have show
notes links to everything we discussed
at tim.blog podcast and until next time
be just a bit Kinder than is necessary
not only to other people but also to
yourself
and as always thank you for tuning in